there is real unity of purpose of coming
together to confront the coronavirus and
I'm confident that in the days ahead
we'll have time to address those issues
and and put into place the kind of
things that will give us visibility on
any infectious disease outbreak in the
future as the country and the world have
come to a standstill to focus on the
Cova 19 outbreak the Trump
administration and the coronavirus task
force team members have been working
every day to keep the American public
safe healthy and informed if you've been
watching the news here on the bench
Shapiro show or anywhere else
people are talking news you've been
seeing the daily press conferences at
the White House they've become a huge
part of our news cycle as the team
breaks down where we currently stand
with the virus and provides new facts
and reports to the American people
president Trump assigned vice president
pens to head this task force in handling
the response for the United States the
team includes many experts from the
White House and other government
agencies along with the nation's
foremost experts on infectious diseases
among these professionals is dr. Deborah
burns who is serving as the team's
response coordinator before this she
spent the last six years acting as the
United States global aids coordinator
working to improve HIV prevention and
treatment today we're bringing you
inside the corona virus task force I'll
be talking to both the vice president
and dr. Burks about how confident they
are we're not going to become like Italy
their response to the media not airing
the White House press briefings and how
long before all of this comes to an end
[Music]
with the country practicing social
distancing and self-quarantine
we've got a bit of a different episode
to bring you today we'll be asking the
vice president of the United States and
dr. Burks the most pressing questions on
everyone's mind right now now normally
this is where I'd say we'll have some
bonus questions at the end of the
conversation for daily wire members
today we're giving everyone the full
interview we've got a fantastic
conversation with our guests and we want
everyone to hear it with that said let's
jump in with Vice President Mike Pence
[Music]
mr. vice president thank you so much for
joining us obviously may be the busiest
person in America really appreciate the
time so let's just jump right in
obviously the big worry right now about
coronavirus is not just the the
mortality rate it's the possibility of
the system being overwhelmed ala Italy
that would be worst-case scenario what
what do you see as the possibility that
that actually happens in areas of the
United States we're tracking it very
closely we're following the data clearly
been in places like Washington state
California and of course the Greater New
York City area we're now more than half
of the coronavirus cases in America have
impacted we're we're working closely
with governors and with state health
officials to make sure that we're
addressing capacity needs the the good
news is is that that you've seen
hospitals all across those regions and
across the country take the president's
guidance to postpone elective surgery
Americans are cooperating with that
that's vastly increased the availability
of beds space in in in those areas and
around the country but it's the American
people should know that we're gonna do
whatever it takes we're building field
hospitals in California and Washington
State in New York the the Navy ship
Comfort and we'll be arriving on Monday
in New York City the Mercy will be in LA
very soon and we're gonna leave no stone
unturned to make sure that our health
care workers have the equipment that
they need and also that our health care
system has the capacity to deal with
people not just those struggling with
coronavirus but of course every American
that continues to deal with deal with
health challenges and and health issues
mr. vice president because our media is
national in scope there's always a lot
of focus on the job of the federal
government what the federal government
does for folks who don't understand sort
of how this federal system plays out
local state and federal how exactly the
responsibilities get divided up in terms
of getting those resources and achieving
those resources well you make a great
point Ben and that is that when it comes
to health issues as I learned when I was
governor of the state of Indiana it is
the local health care workers
and the local officials that are on the
front lines and then a response to a
health crisis like infectious disease is
managed at the state level and it's
federally supported it's one of the
reasons why the president signed a
national emergency declaration and we we
basically stood up the National Response
Center at FEMA now we've got we've got
every state in the Union working
directly with FEMA and we're working
with the Congress to make sure federal
and state agencies and authorities have
the resources that they need but I think
the American people understand that the
nature of our system the way America
works is with that state and local
control whether whether it be health
care issues whether it be education
whether it be law enforcement what we
want to do at the federal level is stand
by and empower those officials that are
leading the effort on the ground and
that's the approach president Trump has
taken and in that being said in the
midst of all of that it would be almost
two weeks ago that the president issued
the 15 days to slow the spread and it's
worth saying to all of your viewers and
listeners that that while there are it's
so while there are areas of the country
where there's significant outbreak we
just mentioned several of them now we're
tracking in the New Orleans area the
Detroit area and people should
absolutely listen to state and local
health authorities about about what's
best to keep themselves and their family
and their loved ones particularly
vulnerable loved ones healthy what every
American can continue to do is to put
the principles of the 15 days to slow
the spread into practice the great news
is we're hearing it all over the country
tens of millions of Americans have been
using the drive-through at a restaurant
avoiding gatherings of more than 10
putting off you know non-essential
travel working from home we have every
confidence that as the data continues to
unfold in the weeks ahead we will see
that the steps of the American people of
families and businesses around the
country across the board has has
significantly impacted this
Fred of the coronavirus in our country
and ultimately saved lives you know
that's the important thing - if I may
bend that the threat of the coronavirus
even to people that contract the disease
the threat of serious illness is very
low that for most Americans especially
young Americans like yourself you'll
have in some cases no symptoms mild
symptoms or flu-like symptoms but there
is a small percentage of Americans
particularly seniors with serious
underlying health conditions and anyone
with an immunodeficiency for whom the
the threat of a serious health outcome
is very real that's why every American
should be putting into practice the
principles of the 15 days to slow the
spread there's no one in America would
ever want to inadvertently expose a
vulnerable American to the corona virus
and and we've been so inspired the way
people have taken that to heart
particularly young people across America
and we have no doubt that it's protected
our vulnerable no doubt that it's saved
lives mr. vice president one of the
things that I've really appreciated
about the administration's response is
the hesitancy to cram down using the
powers of the federal government any
sort of solutions that could be done via
the private sector that's also brought a
lot of criticism on the administration
people suggesting of course that the
defense Protection Act should've been
invoked sooner or invoked differently
what should people know about why the
administration didn't invoke for example
the defense protection act and and start
immediately quote-unquote nationalizing
the supply chains or anything like that
well it's it's a really good point and I
think you've accurately described
president Trump's approach in dealing
with American industry he did initiate
the defense production Act now the
better part of two weeks ago we did use
it when he issued an executive order
that empowered the Justice Department to
aggressively prosecute people that are
price gouging or hoarding critical
medical supplies but the really
inspiring thing is that while the
defense production Act gives the
president the authority to order
businesses to manufacture critical
equipment in times of
or crisis that frankly been every
business that we have asked to step up
has said yes and the approach President
Trump has taken whether it be with major
industries that have stepped forward
many of which are starting to
manufacture ventilators whether it be
companies like Hanes that have started
to manufacture surgical masks for the
first time and distribute millions of
those around the country our first
approach is to say let's let's ask
American businesses to join with us in
an American response and not
surprisingly American businesses are
doing just that mr. vice president in
one second I may ask you about President
Trump coming under fire for suggesting
that we want to get back to work which
of course is true we'll get to that in
just a moment but first here's the
reality you need to give your parents a
present because II haven't seen them in
a long time
right you may not see them for a few
more weeks well how about a great
present where you just go over to their
garage you get all of their old photos
all of their old videos and then you get
those things that digitally preserved
how can you do this well legacy box can
make this happen for you legacy box is a
way for you to easily and affordably
digitally preserve your past it's really
easy you just pack it up send it over
and then you receive perfectly preserved
digital copies on the thumbdrive DVD or
the cloud I've been using legacy box
myself my parents had a bunch of old
film reels went to the garage picked him
up give him the legacy box can't wait to
see what they look like when they get
back you're not just protecting these
memories from a fire over the decades a
lot can happen you can lose photographs
to mold VHS tapes just grow old fall
apart not they even have a VCR DVDs get
scratched a window could be left open
during a storm in there are a thousand
reasons why you can lose these memories
this is why you should get them
digitized legacy box is the world's
largest digitizer of home movies and
photos they've helped over 750 thousand
families digitally preserve their past I
think there's one of most meaningful
gifts you can get somebody I think it's
a great meaningful gift for yourself get
started preserving your past today go to
legacy box comm slash Ben get an
incredible 40 percent off your first
order buy today take advantage of this
exclusive offer sends it in when you are
ready go to legacy box comm /ban say 40%
while supplies last I think it's a
really a deeply important and very
moving thing that you can do for
somebody and for yourself preserve those
memories go to legacy box comm slash Ben
save 40% while supplies last mr. vice
president
obviously the administration has come
under a lot of criticism for even
mentioning the possible
of reopening the economy at some point
in the future which has been bizarre to
me because it seems to me that's the job
of every government official is to try
and determine how we get to the point
where we can actually go back to work we
can't interminably inflate the currency
or borrow from countries that are
themselves experiencing now depressions
or recessions the the fact that so many
people are critical of even attempting
to make those sorts of policy
considerations is bizarre to me but how
exactly is the White House going about
setting up the formula for figuring out
when particular areas get back to work
how exactly what are the inputs on that
on that formula and what does that look
like is it more of an art or science are
there actual metrics being set up well I
like your last word metrics the word
that I hear every single day is data I
mean we have not just the best
infectious disease scientists in the
country but the best in the world that
are part of the White House coronavirus
task force we are analyzing the data
every day thanks to the public-private
partnership that the president
established with commercial labs now
we've done well over a half a million
tests around the country we're
developing very quickly point-of-care
tests that will soon be available at
doctors offices around the country we
have a much better sense of the scope
and the impact of coronavirus around
America today because of the way the
president has marshaled all of the
resources of our our healthcare system
in those incredible commercial labs but
what we're doing now is taking that data
on a day-by-day basis sometimes hour by
hour basis and and we're putting
together the kind of modeling that will
inform the president's decision and you
know the president's made it very clear
he wants to open the country up as soon
as we responsibly can he communicated to
governor's yesterday that that as we
approach the 15th day of 15 days to slow
the spread we would be offering
additional guidance but in the days
ahead will also be analyzing those areas
of the country on a county-by-county
basis been where there's actually very
little outbreak but then letting
governors
make the decision about whether to
reopen schools whether to reopen
businesses they'll always be a certain
measure of social distancing until this
time has passed and we have a vigorous
vaccine for coronavirus and and people
will continue to practice those those
things and we're confident of that but
what the president recognizes is that
it's it's not a choice between putting
the health of America first in the
economy first a strong economy
contributes to the health and well-being
of the American people every day and so
the president is determined following
the data listening to our health experts
to make sure that our governors have the
guidance to be able to make the
decisions about how soon they can open
up their communities and put America
back to work mr. vice president the
media have obviously been unstintingly
critical shockingly of the Trump
administration throughout this entire
process ignoring the fact that the
President did in fact shut down travel
from China and then shut down travel
from the EU dr. Fauci of course agreed
with both of those decisions which the
media seemed to have ignored with all
that said what would you have done
differently what would the president
have done differently if we had the data
now that would then that we have now
throughout this process well I've been
there from the very beginning and I can
tell you back in January when you
remember Ben Washington was most of
Washington was focused on something else
this president marshaled all of our best
scientists in the Oval Office he sat
down he heard about the spread of the
corona virus in China and while we we
would have appreciated hearing earlier
about what was happening in Wuhan
province when the president was
presented that information I was sitting
next to the resolute desk in the Oval
Office when he made the decision on the
spot for the first time in the history
of this country to suspend all travel
from China I was there when he made the
decision to issue travel advisories for
Italy in South Korea and screen all
Americans traveling back to the United
States from either one of those
countries following on that the decision
about Europe the UK and Ireland be what
the president has done in those in
suspending travel had never been
before and all of our health experts are
convinced that it bought us invaluable
time to do everything else the president
has done and that is marshal all the
resources of the federal government we
trust that the Congress this week will
complete its work on legislation to
speed aid to working families some
thirty four hundred dollars a year to a
family of four and direct payments
payroll support for small businesses for
several months support for our major
industries but also those public-private
partnerships like with the commercial
labs like with our health care providers
like with industry that's made medical
supplies work I mean that they're you
know when the president tapped me a
little more than a month ago to lead the
White House coronavirus task force he
said he said Mike I want a
whole-of-government approach by that he
meant federal state local but I knew
very quickly that what he really meant
as I watched him lead was a whole of
America approach and we've engaged the
American people the full power of
American free enterprise and and I'm
more confident every single day that
that partnership is going to hasten the
day that we will get past the
coronavirus that will protect our most
vulnerable and will heal our land
mr. vice president couple more questions
one what do you make in the media many
of whom are deciding that they don't
want to air these White House press
briefings which are incredibly
informative that just because they think
that they don't like what President
Trump is saying and second when all of
this is is said and done and we look
back at this time we look at what China
did very early on what should the
repercussions internationally be for the
fact that China lied about this to the
w-h-o that they didn't reveal the
information to the world that they
allowed five million people to leave Wu
hen province in the middle of the
pandemic and that in all likelihood
right now they're still lying about
their numbers they just shut down all of
their movie theaters again which I
assume they would not be doing if there
were actually no new cases of corona
virus in China it's very important in
the days ahead that we take the lessons
that we've learned and apply them to
international cooperation when it comes
to the spread of infectious disease I'm
confident that we'll do that the
president spoke to President Xi last
night and he spoke to all the g20
leaders yester
day there there is there is real unity
of purpose of coming together to
confront the coronavirus and I'm
confident that in the days ahead we'll
have time to address those issues and
and put into place the kind of things
that will give us visibility on on any
infectious disease outbreak in the
future
well mr. vice-president really
appreciate your time here and thank you
so much for your leadership in what is a
tough time I'm not gonna ask you to
Ballpark when we finally get out of this
but I know that the president has said
weeks not months said do you hold by
that that'll be weeks not months we do
hold by that but it really is in the
hands of the American people I mean the
truth is there are communities around
the country where people need to heed
their state and local authorities the
Greater New York area New York State New
Jersey Washington State California
people need to heed the the counsel of
their state and local officials but if
every American been particularly let me
say the tens of millions of Millennials
who listen to and appreciate your
broadcast in your voice if you will put
into practice the president's
coronavirus guidelines we can hasten the
day that we move our nation past the
corona virus outbreak we can protect the
most vulnerable among us and we can heal
our land but it will take all of us
including young Americans and
Millennials to do it but I have every
confidence that that that Americans of
every age are fully engaged we've all
stepped up we're protecting our most
vulnerable and we'll get through this
Ben well I'd know with all my heart
mr. vice president god bless you god
bless your family and thank you so much
for your time Thank You Ben next up
we're talking with dr. deborah birx I'm
gonna ask her how overwhelmed our
medical resources actually are but first
let's talk about the fact that the
longer you have to stay inside the
weirder and weirder your incognito
web-browsing gets do you really want
people checking that out also this is
like a hackers paradise I've had friends
and family who have been hacked
like right now because everyone in the
world is online like the internet itself
is creaking because so many people are
online this is why you need a VPN I know
how many times I have to say
but VPNs are very important expressvpn
will encrypt 100% of your data with the
best-in-class encryption so your
information is always protected even if
you are using a public Wi-Fi like a cafe
or hotel expressvpn works on everything
phones laptops even routers so everyone
who shares your Wi-Fi can still be
protected even if they don't have
expressvpn installed on their own
devices if you don't use a VPN sort of
your fault right now since I've told you
1,000 times how easy it is to get
Express VPN so go protect your online
activity today with the VPN I trust to
secure my privacy visit my special link
at expressvpn comm slash Ben you get an
extra three months for free on a
one-year package that's expr ESS VPN
comm / Ben expressvpn comm / Ben to
learn more again you need a VPN right
now everybody's online that means there
are a lot of bad people online looking
for your information that information is
yours this is not a good time to have
your credit card number hat go check out
expressvpn comm / Ben that's expr ESS
VPN comm / Ben to learn more once more
expressvpn comm / Ben
[Music]
dr. Deborah Brooks thank you so much for
joining the program really thank you so
much for the time I'm gonna start by
asking you obviously a lot of people are
worried about the overwhelming of
medical resources as we've seen in Italy
that seems to be sort of the chief worry
in New York City what's your confidence
that places like New York City are going
to be able to handle the influx of
coronavirus patients coming in that
there will be enough ICU beds or
ventilators well I think all of us are
tracking day by day minute by minute the
number of beds the bed utilization the
ventilator utilization across all of New
York City realizing that we have built
additional hospitals there and of course
we're bringing the ship up so between
all of those pieces together I think we
have a very high confidence level
otherwise we would bring be bringing in
more material for New York City
dr. Brooks you're criticized this week
for explaining to the media that perhaps
they shouldn't be using all of the most
extreme sort of predictions of how bad
this pandemic was going to be and
obviously there have been a wide variety
of sort of predictions as to both
mortality rate and infection rate how do
you determine what you think the
mortality rate of Kovan 19 is as well as
the infection rate and and why do you
think the media are playing up sort of
the most extreme examples of how many
people they think are gonna be infected
or die well we use we use data so we
start out by looking at the models very
early on we were all using models and
then we actually go to the actual data
of what happened in South Korea what
happened in China what's happening in
Spain and Italy and then we adjust our
assumptions based on what's happening in
real life on the ground models are
terrific and I think they've been really
helpful in being able to predict how our
mitigation methods should work when we
put them all together and so that part
of the modeling is terrific but the
predictions around the number of
Americans who will get infected and I
think critically more importantly the
number of Americans that will actually
have significant disease are two very
different things and so that's why we've
been tracking very closely a real ground
experience of what's happening in each
of the countries it seems like a lot of
those statistics are based on the amount
of testing available we don't at this
point have testing in place for Cyril
prevalence for antibodies so we can't
tell how many people have actually had
it and been cleared of it obviously
testing is not wide enough at this point
that we can even tell who has it in is
asymptomatic which may be ten times
or people who have it and are in our
symptomatic which suggest that the the
mortality rates that are being bandied
about are may be in order of magnitude
too high that certainly you know we've
seen that the numbers that the WHL
originally put out three to four percent
on this thing seem to be far too high
where would you peg at this point the
range of possible mortality rates on
kovat 19:00 well in those few sentences
you summarized exactly what's happening
so that was brilliant so I mean what the
part of this is is how many people are
really asymptomatic so we have case
detection and we're pretty confident on
that those are cases that come to the
hospital those are cases that we've
tested the hospital our testing rates in
hospitals are running about 30-40
percent so that still shows that 70 60
70 percent of the individual the
patients coming to the hospital with
severe respiratory disease are not covin
but we're tracking that very carefully
but you really captured what is our
biggest question our biggest question is
how much asymptomatic individuals are
out there and are they actively
spreading the virus unknown to them and
so I think we're very confident in the
cases we're very confident in
understanding how many of those cases
that percent will go to severe disease
what we're not confident in is the total
number of people that are infected and
you really captured that well the way to
do it in the way we will be able to do
it is look at antibody levels because
those are preserved for long periods of
time for weeks months and potentially
even years so we'll be able to figure it
out after we move through the crisis and
we're trying to bring testing on board
but we're very interested in how many
people are asymptomatic versus how many
people present with symptoms so dr.
Brooks and one second ona asked about
the possibility of a second wave we've
seen some second wave infections in
places like Hong Kong and China we'll
get to that in just one moment first you
should as a responsible person have
insurance for the things that you care
about and one of those things that you
care about obviously is your life I mean
you want to make sure that your family
is taken care of in case god forbid
something should happen to you this is
where policy genius can help policy
genius makes finding the right life
insurance a breeze in minutes you can
compare quotes from the top insurers and
find your best price it could save
fifteen hundred bucks or more every year
by using policy genius to compare life
insurance policies once you apply the
policy genius team handles all the
paperwork and the red tape for free and
policy genius doesn't just make life
insurance easy
they can also help you find the right
home auto disability insurance they'll
even help you bundle home and auto
insurance really competitively shop and
get the best policy for you so if you
don't know what's just around the corner
that's ok nobody does but you can be
prepared for anything
with life insurance in just a few
minutes you can find your best price and
apply at policy genius.com policy genius
we're always gonna get the future wrong
better to get life insurance right if
you're a responsible human being you
want to make sure that your family is
insured in case god forbid something
should happen to you go check out policy
genius.com right now get all of your
insurance needs taken care of that's
policy genius.com dr. Brooks how long is
this containable and and what is the
sort of prospect for containment so
we've seen in China they just shut down
their movie theaters again which would
suggest that obviously they are not
completely saying when about the
prospects for a coronavirus over there
we've also seen the possibility of
second wave infections in places like
Hong Kong and in Singapore and Taiwan
even if we let ourselves out from this
generalised lockdown that's happening
across the country how confident are we
that when we do that there won't be a
second wave of cases and how can we
mitigate the possibility of that well
that's really an important question so
what's happening in China right now is
they're getting imported cases so
exactly what's happening to them is what
happened to the rest of the world two
and three months ago
and it's very interesting how
everybody's reacting to it I mean
they're shutting down things and saying
people don't come into our country and
then very early in the epidemic when the
rest of the world was saying that even
the head of w-h-o said well we shouldn't
stop air transport and traffic and so
it's very interesting China has come
around to the way the Europe and the
United States is looking at it because
they don't want new cases coming into
China so everybody understands now how
this is moved around the world we have
not seen second waves in this in the
sense that sometimes in epidemics you'll
have a first wave and a second wave
internal to the country what people are
worried about now are receding new new
cases from outside and I think that's
what we remain very vigilant on and so
in the United States we're tracking
county by county to really understand
what's happening at the most granular
level because then you can really laser
focus the kind of mitigate
that each single County needs in each
single state in order to be really
focused on what needs to occur so how
exactly is the coordination go on in the
white house between the public health
team and the team that's more focused on
the economic side so that the
administration has come in for criticism
for suggesting we have to reopen the
economy which is bizarre because
presumably everyone wants to reopen the
economy only the question is when and
how which are of course the big
questions so how does that coordination
go on because if you're a public health
official I would assume that your sole
goal at this point is shut this thing
down shut it down as long as possible
and at the same time you know there are
health consequences and the economy is
real people millions of people losing
their jobs this week how do those needs
get balanced out how does that
conversation go at the White House well
the good news is both the economic group
and the public health group are meeting
together every day and what's been
really seamless to me is both are using
data so they're used to looking at data
and very real-time we're used to looking
at data in real time so we both very
much appreciate what each person's
bringing to the table and those are
really the critical discussions I think
you think see early on we were using
really blunt instruments and what do I
mean by that we are bringing in
everything look you know this is what's
closing the schools does this is what
social distancing does this is what
washing your hands multiple times a day
this is what probably the most important
thing if I could leave with your
listeners is don't touch your face
because you forget where your hands have
been you've touched things a toy a knob
of this of that and now we know hard
surfaces actually can maintain the virus
and so the teams working are working
together in a very seamless way because
they understand the date of each other's
is print presenting at the table so
that's been really helpful in bringing
people together
dr. Brooks you mentioned not touching
your face there was a lot of talk very
early on this sort of bifurcated message
coming from the media and some members
of government suggesting that face masks
are useless you shouldn't bother with
them but also health care professionals
should have face masks and that's very
difficult I think for most people to
understand why it is that the people who
are most vulnerable to this should have
face masks but but you should not
obviously we've seen a wide prevalence
of face masks in places like South Korea
that is heavily used do you think that
that is a future path for the
it's when we start to get back to work
the people are using if not n95 face
masks some other form of face masks that
prevents them from maybe touching their
mouth or their noses often or at least
coughing germs out into the air
yeah so I'm Southeast Asia in general is
very facemask oriented I've worked over
there for many decades and it started
out very much around pollution and then
adapted very much into preventing spread
of viruses so it's a culture that in
general out in public normally wears
face masks so if you go to Vietnam and
you go to Bangkok Thailand
you'll see a lot of people wearing that
face mask so it's very normal in their
culture so adding that on was something
they would naturally do there's evidence
that for someone who is sick them
wearing a face mask does protect others
from getting infected it's not totally
clear that a face mask in the general
public is is really additive because
your exposures are so alternate you know
the one time you forget it and you're
out in public so in the hospital
situation it makes a lot of sense but in
general public and I think people will
start looking at it I think the biggest
cons long-term consequences of this is
people will learn how to interact
verbally rather than always touching and
handshakes because we know a lot of
viruses are spread that way so dr.
Burton a second oh and ask you about
what other countries have been doing to
deal with coral virus because they
haven't been nearly as restrictive as
the United States could that work here
if not why not we'll get to that in just
one second first let's talk about the
ear buds that you are using to listen to
this right now sorry using those old
fashioned ear buds the one with the
wires you stick them in your pocket
they're all tangled up when you take
them out at six a half an hour to
untangle them by that time the show is
over
you need wireless earbuds you're living
in the 21st century and this is why you
need Rea cons Rea Khan has just released
their best model yet
the e25 they have six hours of playtime
seamless bluetooth pairing more bass a
more compact design that gives you a
nice noise isolating fit rate cons
wireless earbuds are really comfortable
they're perfect for on-the-go listening
and for taking up phone calls one of the
things I like about Rea con is that they
perfectly fit my ear a lot of
traditional ear buds actually are
one-size-fits-all well if your ear is
not a one-size-fits-all ear you may need
Rea cons because they have a variety of
options on how they fit your they send
you a little metal
it's got some pieces on it that allow
you to customize the fit to your ear
unlike some of your other wireless
options rake on earbuds are stylish and
discreet no dangling wires no stems they
come in a variety of fits they also come
in a variety of colors they look pretty
cool pick up a pair and see what the
hype is all about now is the time to get
the latest and greatest from rake on 15%
off your order at buy rake on Comm /ban
that's Bui RA Y Co n comm slash man for
15% off rake on wireless earbuds buy
rake on comm slash been dr. Bert's there
there are some countries that have not
taken these sort of really large-scale
steps that you've seen in places like
Italy or places like the United States
obviously South Korea comes to mind
where there's heavy surveillance but
there was heavy testing originally but
even some countries like the Netherlands
in Sweden have been a lot less
restrictive in terms of public behavior
they've kept restaurants open but told
people to eat at the tables as opposed
to eating at the bars some of them only
recently shut down schools even New York
Governor Cuomo suggested maybe it was
the wrong thing to shut down the schools
because you ended up sending kids home
with their grandparents so why do you
think that those solutions in places
like the Netherlands in Sweden were less
likely to work in the United States or
do you think that maybe those are going
to be sort of the the ways that we step
back into a normal life when as this
thing begins to wane well there's
certainly reasonable to study them and
and so I think decisions people have
made is really helping us understand the
impact of those decisions when you have
enough countries doing enough different
things it really helps you to be able to
do this multivariate analysis to really
get an idea of what worked better
because what everybody did is put
together everything that has been shown
in the past to have an impact because
after seeing the numbers and the
logarithmic spread in Italy I think
everybody woke up now Sweden would have
many less seeds what do I mean by that
so many less individuals from China go
to Sweden in the winter because it's
it's a little dark Sun Goes Down about
230 so there's it's not a hot spot for
visitation May when the Sun is up a
really long time and it's up till 2 or 3
o'clock in the morning they have a lot
of visitors and so I think they didn't
get exposed to the virus in the same way
that the majority of the more southern
countries of Europe Scott got expose
so you look at the rates in Switzerland
which is a multi-country
dynamic situation they also pretty have
pretty high rates of infections so going
back and really studying the Netherlands
all of this spread occurred by people
traveling around the world and so the
difference between people ask me all the
time what's the difference between SARS
and this kovat 19 the difference was in
2003 almost no one traveled outside of
China and now millions and millions and
millions of individuals travel around
the world from China so it really
exposed the entire globe to this new
virus it could have come from anywhere
we're just a very much more travelling
group than we were in the past
dr. Brooks as we move forward with all
of this yeah there's been talk in the
media about not airing press briefings
from the White House for some odd reason
do you think that that is a good idea or
a bad idea for for the media to stop
airing the press briefings or cut them
short I don't know why they would want
to cut them short I mean there's a lot
of data brought to that press briefing
every single day all of the decisions
coming out of the task force is brought
there the new therapeutic studies that
are ongoing the new vaccine studies the
new testing platforms that we have
available the new innovations we brought
in testing that all comes out to that on
press briefing and we've really been
using those briefings to inform the
American public about the changes that
are being made to decrease bureaucracy
and make more things available as well
as PE but also therapeutics vaccines and
new options and testing and it's a
really important way for us to
communicate to the American people I
don't know how the American people would
know all of these changes and what
options are available to them if they
didn't have the press briefing dr. Burks
obviously the Trump administration
President Trump has said that he is
hoping for weeks not months here
obviously we don't dictate how the virus
goes but we dictate our response to the
virus if you were to lay a timeline
across him obviously I'm not gonna hold
you to anything that you predict here
but if we were gonna lay a timeline are
we talking weeks not months are we
talking the end of summer the beginning
of summer before at least we start to
make the transition back to people going
back to work and people starting to
interact with one another again even if
we are not shaking hands
yeah so if you look at the history of
these RNA viruses of which this is one
RSV or a virus that might infect your
children very common in the winter in
children so fluke these chrono viruses
like this covet 19 and RSV they have a
very seasonal peak normally we don't
have an experience with this virus but I
think for your audience if they go back
and look at what the normal seasonality
of these viruses are and then that they
overlay that with the experience in both
Italy South Korea and China I think
people can come to their own conclusions
that is exactly what we're looking at to
really understand how this virus is
moving through a population but the one
thing that can change weeks to months is
individuals not following the guidance
now because we know that this is many
places the maximum time of spreading and
so that's why the president was very
clear on these guidelines and how
important they are that every American
follows them
well dr. Brooks thank you so much for
your time god bless you and stay healthy
out there really appreciate your work on
this
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro shows Sunday special is
directed by Mike Joyner and produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring associate producer case Winterton
our guests are booked by Kaitlyn Maynard
post-production is supervised by Alex's
Singaram editing is by Jim nickel audio
is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and makeup
is by Nika Geneva title graphics are by
Cynthia Angulo the ventia Pierrot shows
Sunday special is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
[Music]